good morning friends I'm Alana and today
I wanted to show you who I Jan's daily
fix gets made from start to finish so
this process actually starts before I
even wake up in the morning I'm used
freelance at Evan Campbell who lives on
the East Coast and therefore he's a few
hours ahead of everyone else in San
Francisco is tasked with finding new
stories for edgy and to cover in the
morning when it gets to about 9:00 a.m.
Evan starts talking about what he's
seeing what the news stories he's
covered on to update us on everything
that has happened that morning and also
the stories that are trending the best
on ign.com
from there we talk about which stories
we like the most which ones we think
might be the headline which ones work
for the fix and which ones won't
necessarily because there are certain
stories that won't necessarily appeal
anything that's overly technical or
requires a lot of detail probably won't
work that well on the fix well we can
only have three stories and the show
format is that it's quite fast usually
while Evans writing the script and often
we've had the conversation about what
stories we pick I stopped putting on my
makeup to get ready to shoot because the
turnaround for the fix is pretty quick
once I finished makeup the script is
usually good for me to edit so I jump in
and I rewrite a lot of it every right
sentences to sound a little different I
add in some of my knowledge on topics
sometimes I'll ask Evan for
clarification on a story that I'm not
familiar with so it really is a group
effort we also have the two other
producers Dan and John who read over the
script to make sure everything is okay
before we head into the studio and start
shooting hey this is Joe Vitt he's
putting the script into the teleprompter
which is then controlled by this thingy
which i think is actually very cool and
then over here we have all of the
cameras you can see that Stan this is
John one of our producers all right John
what's up not much
hi Dan what's up Oh busy day alright as
usual so we do the thing let's do things
this is a studio setting up all this is
actually really simple of as a button on
one of the computers in the control room
that turns on all the mud it is makes
the lights all the right colors and
there are markings on the pool so the
cameras are set up in the right place
it's all very automated so this is the
pot where we film they're all in there
and then and then I'm over here this is
how I make sure my hair doesn't look
terrible but it mostly does when will
kids blonde playing with the Predators
honor and tech is a bad idea this might
have been why the new season took so
long agreeing to produce 70 episodes of
a show sounds like hell and that's your
daily fix for may 10th now that you're
all caught up watch our video review for
city of Ross we describe the game as a
torture chamber so I might try to avoid
that oh you say brass yeah now sticking
with a lot of people who mad at me for
how I said Los Angeles yesterday my
accent can we make drool out of your
mouth turn on the bottle oh yeah weird I
don't know good morning
[Music]
I'm just doing aggressive excitement
right now all right that works so we've
shot the thing we get the stills and
then we go into the backroom and export
them and then immediately put them in an
email we send this off to our art team
and we loop in everyone else who's
working on the fix for that day we take
a lot of photos for stills and we send
the art team a bunch of options so they
have a lot to work with so they can pick
what's easiest as the stills are being
sent off we're also asking for what's
called a plasma which is the thing that
appears on the screen next to me and at
the same time the video is sent off to
out video that it is so this is kalila
who edits the fix how does this process
work I will edit the arrow on this
timeline to make sure it's all cook he
said all the stuff that goes over the
top is stuff that we have like pre-built
right so the headline bar and which is
this and then the daily fix logo is
already pre-built the logo the plasma
minus the image is already built that's
my buddy our team yeah
all dislike the audio and the effects
are already in the project as well as
the opening bumper so you sort of add in
the text the overlay yeah and then what
we are all on top of Sutton Potts yeah
so usually what I do is for this is
actually the script I usually just like
make sure that you get down like your
first sentence and then get right into
the b-roll right after that and so then
this is for h2 so it'll be like gameplay
footage and then back to you before you
switch to your next subject
when we do when we have quotes we use
Photoshop which is this is already
pre-built we just have to change the
quote not in a new picture and then
change the title and name of whoever is
saying the quote and we just add that
over b-roll and blur out would be b-roll
underneath so this is more for so then
once you've finished editing what
happens I have to render it get damn to
screen in and then I export it out and I
uploaded into our CMS so while the video
is being added myself Dan John and
Jonathan Dolan butch who is one of our
news editors all work on the headline
you have to focus on what's going to
make people click on the video but we
also have to focus on being accurate
Jonathan's there as a news writer to
make sure everything fits without use
guidelines and we brainstorm a whole
bunch of ideas before we actually settle
on a headline and generally around the
time that the video editor has finished
editing the video is about the same time
that we have finally locked in when our
headline is going to be this from there
Dan takes the video puts the headline on
it and gets it published on ign.com then
I usually spend the first hour in the
comments responding to people while I'm
working on other stuff does depend on
how busy my day is but I do try my best
to do that and this takes us right up to
5 p.m. we share the link without social
team we make sure it gets shed on
Twitter and on Facebook and then we saw
it again the next morning I hope you
guys found this video even slightly
interesting people have been asking me
to make it for quite a while so thank
you to everyone whose names are on
screen right now time please let me know
if you want to see more stuff like this
with that I'm a lot of PS don't forget
to download the IGN app and remember you
can get your fix anytime online at IGN